well indeed a long struggle it looked
like you were better throughout he
played a surprising dragon against you
what were your thoughts about this end
game though when you played rook c7
did you feel like you should still be
able to win this position um yeah i mean
definitely was thinking that i'm winning
uh in this end game but it wasn't easy
at all uh daniel put like great fight
there and i thought
i mean i thought i'm winning when i was
going there but i started calculating
looking at some lines and i couldn't
figure out what to do and how to win
like you know move by move and so on so
uh at some point in the end game uh
dania played move king c7 which i
thought was very nice
and
after this
i'm
i'm probably winning but i wasn't sure
at the board at all let's pull it up on
screen uh this position because
we had a little argument break out in
the studio about winning it was it was
small because yasser you know likes to
likes to poke the bear but i think he
did feel that yasser that this position
was drawing was a draw yeah so what are
your thoughts in this this position here
about whether or not uh if if black had
kept the bishop on the f4 square
how would you have tried to win this was
the best defense and i actually was
thinking about it for
all my time pretty much when i was
thinking so yes basically it's
unavoidable that we've got position king
of kings let's say e4 i'll probably go
king e6 king f7 just before this point
go to the g5
but anyway probably the same thing and
here i was uh
thinking that my plan to win would be uh
not king because dania told me that he
missed uh king f or like he he thought
after king a freaking g4 i'll just play
g3 and i win the g5 come back here just
go back [ __ ] on c7 and keep my point
different oh wow so that's uh that's
that's the issue uh however uh i
wouldn't play g3 and i had a different
plan of trying to win this in this
position as instead of king g4 i would
have played my own pawn on g4
and now and then i would play bishop b5
and because i don't think danya can do
anything so i was just thinking all
right i play put my phone on g4 can you
can get three bishop b5 then i play c4
and c5 at some point daniel would
probably have to give away this e3 pawn
and then if i can manage to get my pawn
to uh c5 i should be winning uh but it
is very important to actually have to be
honest king has to be on the frequency
so let's say you know king of three we
should be five
king b6 bishop b5 let's say
uh king of three let's say k7 g4 for
instance uh king b6 bishop b5 for
example
uh he could have put it there yes
doesn't really matter the order and now
c4 so i was thinking about such position
and uh if king a7 i have c5 it's kind of
kind of like super small it seems like
but maybe he can just defend by giving
away the e pawn and somehow hold it but
then i will probably i mean i had ideas
of getting my king to d5 coming between
sigma to be seven depends of course at
some point if our game get to play c5 i
should be winning because so what if i
go king a7 and when you go c5 i go
bishop h2
uh how king a7 bc5 bishop h2 uh it's a
very good question we should be two
let's say
bishop p2 bishop f4 king e4
bishop h2
um right uh now king d5
well this was something like this in the
game actually wasn't it like i just want
to play king 667 and just push this is
probably over that's problems so i saw
lines like this when i was going
why i give you everything you want
bishop goes uh c6 king e6 yeah okay just
put your king everywhere you want okay
phone goes
awesome all right either forward g7 c7
ah yes and it's over and i'm not nothing
is not very good very good so i saw
those ideas and i thought it was winning
but you know at the board i was never
sure probably engines will show that
what's going on all the engine shows
that you are winning
okay
so your idea was in the game go g4
bishop king f3 bishop d5 and that's
right i think on f3 it's fantastic king
of being drinking three bishop to b5 c4
and then around sort of wow
so i saw those ideas and that's why i
went for it um
but because this king certainly kind of
moved from me over a little bit because
uh i thought a7 i can win just right
away but it wasn't so easy because uh
just e2 await queen e1 queen and uh yes
so basically a7 e2 a8 queen and the
e1 queen and this end game was also very
interesting
you